so today we're going to be doing this
machine learning for transcriptomic data
workshop that is intended for people to
quickly get through the basic concepts
of RNA seek and then continue on to
explore the table of expression using
machine learning methods supervised and
unsupervised methods as well as being
able to visualize the results and share
a specific issues of interest within the
data set that we can alized
first of all to make this possible and
to do this quickly we are going to be
using as a multi-omics data analysis and
processing platform called t-- bio info
the platform was designed for processing
analysis and integration of multi omics
data and it is used in research so this
is a real research product you will see
that on the platform there are many
different sections and many different
data types today we will focus on
transcriptomics so the section that will
allow us to process raw RNA seek data
and also to establish some differences
within the data such as differential
gene expression on quantified mapped
reads the second section that we'll be
talking about today is data mining and
under data mining you see that there are
two sub sections called supervised
analysis and unsupervised analysis and
those two methods those two types of
methods can help us first explore and
visualize these large data sets as well
as then build classifiers that allow us
to identify gene signatures responsible
for division of this sample group of
samples into groups finally we'll also
be using this utility section and this
utility sections allow us to annotate
the gene names and then understand how
the expression of these genes can be
mapped onto pathways
and help us interpret the biological
meaning of what we identified so let's
go through this in a little bit more
detail
first of all processing raw reads and
generating a table of expression to do
that we will build a pipeline and then
we will take a look at how these
outcomes the outputs of the pipeline
could be visualized and what can we see
within that table of expression the
second part that we will focus on is
unsupervised and supervised analysis of
the gene expression table where we'll
look at things like principal component
analysis clustering and then under
supervised analysis we will do
differential gene expression analysis
that will help us select specific genes
but also we look at classification
methods to determine which group should
a sample be associated with finally we
will look at the annotation where we can
select a number of genes and convert
them into gene IDs so simple name of the
gene as well as gene ontology or that
gene and then we can use differential
gene expression and then we can use
differential gene expression output and
map it on to pathways seeing which genes
are upregulated and downregulated on
which pathways before I continue I'm
just going to make sure that everybody's
with us and that everybody can hear what
we are doing so if you have any
questions we will try and address those
questions in specific times between the
sections let's just make sure that
everybody has everything technically
working so you know where the chatbox is
you have the presentation you also have
the files that we're going to be using
here and we are also going to be putting
this workshop in a video format at the
end so if you ever want to go back and
review the
cereal you will be able to do that going
back to our presentation to illustrate
many of these things we will be using a
single data set and this data set is a
publicly available data set around the
topics of precision medicine why
precision medicine what are we going to
be looking at and how is this relevant
to the type of data that we are
analyzing first of all precision
medicine in the context of oncology a
lot of times is around the challenge of
classifying a specific subtype of a
disease in our case we're going to be
dealing with breast cancer so here you
see a mammogram and you see this white
spot and this white spot is a tumor and
so the challenge to understand what type
of cancer this is we can look at first
of all the origin of the tumor so what
tissue is it coming from and you can see
in the mammogram that it's not so clear
where it's coming from
but also we have other tools for example
immunohistochemistry allows us to look
at expressed proteins by staining the
tissue but the limitation of this is of
course that you can only stain the
tissue so many times and so you're
limited to the number of expressed
proteins that you can look at the next
step in our ability to classify samples
is around gene expression so here you
see a microarray expression of 50 genes
and you can see the high expression in
green and the low expression in red and
you can see how they vary between
different subtypes of cancer why is this
important first of all it's important
because we're looking at predictive
signatures that allow us to
differentiate between cancers that are
more aggressive less aggressive and are
related to the survival but also at
specific issues around recurrence so
cancer does not come once and then
disappear a lot of times it comes
back and so it's important to understand
what is the likelihood of a specific
cancer to come back here you can see an
example of a survival curve and a
recurrence curve for patients and the
comparison of two panels that allows to
do that so the panels each one contains
a different number of genes and based on
a specific pattern of expression we can
classify patients into high risk low
risk and medium risk another use for
this to understand what subtype of
cancer we're looking at is selection of
therapy we can use therapeutic
interventions like surgery radiotherapy
and chemotherapy all of these have
different effects on the cancer itself
but also on the surrounding tissues and
so we can use them more appropriately if
we can classify the cancers in a more
precise way the other aspect of
precision medicine or personalized
medicine is to understand the biology
that is unique to the patients and we
can then prescribe drugs that are
targeting specific biology and
intervening in a process now this is a
much more complex process where we need
to understand the unique aspect of the
cancer in the context of a unique
patient and so some of the things that
we'll be looking at today are related to
this concept as well in fact the paper
that we are going to be using and The
Associated data set is a paper that is
called modeling precision treatment of
breast cancer as you can see these are
cell lines so they are cells derived
from a tumor from a patient and then
they're grown in a cell culture and that
cell culture represents what is
happening in the tumor but at the same
time these tumors are treated or these
cell lines these cell cultures are
treated with different types of
therapeutics so different types of
molecules and then we also have a data
set that measures the reduction in its
ability to
proliferate so the division of the cells
is stopped by these different
therapeutics and we can compare them how
they interact with different cancers so
now we're not going to be looking at
every aspect of this data set we're not
going to be using the multi-omics and
we're not really going to be looking at
the treatment but we are going to be
looking at the different types of
cancers represented in this data set in
this paper all of you should have these
input files so let's just take a moment
and check that you do have them if you
if you downloaded then you can see in
your browser here I'm going to open mine
it's called workshop underscore SN
underscore May and then inside you have
multiple folders so please let us know
if you don't have the files that's an
important part of it so the other part
of it is you need to have access to the
platform so if you go to the platform
server dot T - bio info and then you
should have received login information
so you can go ahead and login right now
and after you login you will see this
table of areas of analysis so if you
don't see this please let us know and we
will help you get there okay
that everybody has the files let's go
under input files an expression
quantification the folder called
expression quantification and then there
you will see this file called samples
dot SPL okay so if you don't have the
files where can you get the files you
can go on this page so I will put the
link right here and then if you scroll
down under the video you see this button
called download file and in fact it will
just be this link so if you download
this link you will be able to see a
zipped file so it will look something
like this workshop underscore SN
underscore may when you open this file
and you see input files right here and
then under input files you will see
expression quantification and samples
SPL okay so what is what is inside this
file inside this file we just simply
have links to fast you file so you see
that it's got fq that stands for fast
queue and then you will notice
underscore one other score too that
means that it's bare end files and so
each file will be repeated twice with a
different extension of you you have any
questions or you don't have this again
let us know what's that help you now
before we continue to the next section I
just want to point out that a lot of
this material is also covered in our
online courses we have three courses
dedicated to transcriptomics and they go
from easy or introductory
transcriptomics one intermediate
transcriptomics two and two advanced
which is transcriptomics three these
courses cover the basics of converting
raw files to gene expression table
analyzing that expression thing
using standard approaches like student
t-test and then additional approaches
used in differential gene expression as
well as a more advanced course on
machine learning that introduces
unsupervised and supervised approaches
to interrogate that data and mine it and
then visualize the results okay we don't
have any more questions I'm going to
continue to RNA seek and the processing
of data what we will try to do here is
take the raw reads the files that we
have in the svl file and then create a
pipeline that converts these raw reads
into a table that we can actually look
at so before we do that let's understand
a little bit what are we dealing with so
this is Machino some sequence in the
genome and we have in this sequence a
number of genes there's a gene a gene B
and gene C now not all genes are going
to be expressed so we will only have for
example a transcript a and transcript
see those in turn are turned into reads
and so we have many many reads that
represent many genes so one of the
challenges that we have is mapping those
reads back to those genes and then
quantifying the reads aligned with
specific genes but it's not so simple in
fact there are some additional details
that we need to consider in fact the
real process goes starts from shattering
the RNA so we have these reads and then
we use adapters to to match to those
different reads and then we use PCR to
amplify the reads
so we have many many reads that include
the adapters and there's some effective
PCR amplification and then finally we
have the process of reading because of
this we are going to look at three
components of RNA seek data analysis the
first compose
is pre-processing so we want to remove
the adapters and we do some additional
trimming and then we want to remove
technical PCR duplicate the second part
is mapping after we've removed adapters
and PCR duplicates we are going to map
the reads unknown transcripts
transcripts that are associated with
genes and recorded in a GTF file then
we're going to map on genome that's an
optional step specifically it's useful
for identification of novel transcript
so variation of the mound genes and then
we can look at a combined strategy a
strategy where we will create a pipeline
that will give an output of all the
known genes as well as transcripts and
potentially we can even go as far as
just table of exons so that we can deal
with unknown sequences that might be of
interesting interest at the end once
those reads are aligned we can quantify
them and one of the questions is going
to be around how to quantify them do we
just count the number of reads or do we
account for certain differences in genes
for example their length that will have
an impact on the variation that we want
to study so now this is the picture of
the RNA seat section and you can see
that the same color coding blue red and
green is going to be on the platform you
will see that the blue buttons are
associated with pre-processing the red
are associated with mapping bowtie to T
and the green is associated with
expression levels of quantifying those
reads now let's go to the platform and
create our first pipeline let me know if
everybody by now has access to the
platform and has all the files
I'm just gonna give a moment if you want
to ask a question you don't have
anything just go ahead and ask right now
okay if not let us go so RNA seek I
click on it very similar interface is
common to all of the other sections but
let's take a look over here first of all
on top we have the inputs that we're
going to be using for the files that we
load into the pipeline so we have a
section a selection here for our model
genome GTF which means that we're going
to be using a model of reference genome
with an associated prepared GTF file
that contains the mapping or the
positions of all of the genes if you are
dealing with a non model organism you
would of course choose reference genome
gpf if it is annotated or you can also
use a non annotated the second thing we
have here is single end or pair and
leads so in our case I showed you we
have the underscore wanting to therefore
we have pair and read so we're gonna
select PD there are a number of
different types of files that the
platform can handle and we're working at
fast youth files and finally we're going
to be using the commune of the human
genome grch38 while once we click upload
files you see that there are a few
options you can upload individual files
you can use reference links such as svl
HTTP and FTP SPL is a reference file on
the server that you are using and we are
going to use URL bulk upload because we
already have this file with all of the
links inside a single file so I'm going
to go back to our input files
somebody yeah okay I'm sorry
my niece
um who you on you okay somebody else is
calling in so again if you have any
questions
you
uploaded little select define groups
check in our case we're not going to be
doing differential gene expression so we
have to say cancel no groups and now we
can build our pipeline okay so it looks
like mono can't log in did you receive
the login details it would be great
Sahil if you can try and work with Manu
to get him on the platform sure yeah I
do that okay if anybody else is having a
difficulty to login you should have
received an email and in this email say
he'll provided you with access to the
platform let's see so you will get a
platform URL and then you will have your
username is your email and some password
that he emailed to you so again if you
don't have that just reach out to see
he'll and he will try and help you in
the meantime we were able to upload the
SPL file and start creating the pipeline
so I will start with clicking on start
and here I can read a little bit about
the process of our NHC and then I have
this pre-processing section so the blue
section that we talked about cinematic
is a method to trim technical sequences
so there is a database that stores these
different sequences and then the
algorithm removes those sequences and
you can read more about this algorithm
by clicking this link after traumatic we
are going to remove the PCR
amplification so it again using a
statistical approach to clean all
duplicate leads from raw sequencing data
if you would like to read more about PCR
amplification you can go to this link
and so now we've connected these two
buttons and after we
connected these two buttons we have
clean breeds and so the next step is to
map those weeks on to the known
transcripts so we're going to be using
bowtie 2 and later on we'll look at an
alternative to this pipeline but if you
want to read about bowtie two again it's
a fairly complex approach to identifying
where the lead should be map you can
read this publication and understand a
little bit more of the algorithm behind
this method but say and then after we've
mapped them we are going to be
quantifying the reads the alignment of
leads the number of reads that fall
under a specific region in in a in a
type of a number so we'll talk a little
bit about what those numbers are in the
meantime here's an algorithm that
provides several options and it's called
our SEM and you can read about this
algorithm right here now what are the
options we can either count in fpkm
expected account or TPM in our case
let's use fpkm
and then later on we'll talk about what
are the different approaches here and
how do they relate to our ability to
quantify gene level of gene expression
you can also see that we have the option
to create an enzyme table in our case we
don't need to do that because we
actually are mapping just on the full
known transcript and so we can click end
and this is rna-seq pipeline of course
if you want to you can not even do the
pre-processing steps but we will see a
little bit later in the presentation
that it does have an impact on the
outfit so let's call this you can call
it whatever you want but I'm just going
to call it RNA seek simple bye bye and
click on safe okay
everybody is on and let's run this
pipeline now running this pipeline is
going to take a long time so we're not
going to wait for the pipeline to finish
fish but just to make sure that you
understand on the platform every time
after you create the pipeline you need
to click run pipeline and if you didn't
you can also see under my pipelines they
are prepared pipelines that look like
this and then there are processing
pipelines and completed pipelines so if
yours looks like this that means you
have not started it if it's looking like
this that means you already started to
process that data now we're not going to
wait for the pipeline to finish though
I'm going to show you the output of the
of the pipeline and then we can talk
about what is inside the table but let
us return to the presentation for a
second and do a little bit of practice
so before we look at the output and some
of the considerations please try and
create a different pipeline I'll do this
with you but if you want to try it on
your own go ahead we will use the same
svl file we will take some
pre-processing steps cinematic and then
PCR Queen we will use a different mapper
called high SAP tube we will then create
some isoforms using cufflinks merge them
onto the GTF file using cut march map
this on transcripts using bowtie cutie
and then quantify the reads using our
SEM X table okay let's do that
I will go under RNA see if you remember
the settings over here I'm not going to
explain them again because we just went
through all of this but remember that
we're going to be using the same as we
also - URL upload let's not do any group
so painful milk groups start cinematic
PCR clean icesat-2
cufflinks half-month
bowtie gt-r some inspiration table and
then
okay let me know if you successfully
created a pipeline if you have not maybe
you need a little bit more time to go
over the pipeline so let us know but we
will give a few more pipelines during
this session so you'll have plenty of
time to find okay here's an example
pipeline that you should have received
by now or you should see on your screen
right so if I take a look over here
again I can see what I see right here so
what did we do we uploaded the same as
VL files we trimmed the technical
technical sequences we remove the
duplicates from our PCR mapped it using
a different mapper then we combined
those map leads into a GTF and then map
that onto knowing transcripts and
received an expression table now we also
have the option to add the eggs on table
here but we're not really going to be
looking at it in this session so you can
but you don't have to create that for
your pipeline now let's take a look at
the outlet so you can see that the
output table is going to have ids of
genes and then sample names on top and
so the columns are associated with the
samples and for each gene for each
sample I have a specific company okay so
let's go ahead and look under our
downloaded files instead of input files
we will look at how to files and under
expression quantification you will see
two files so you will see fpkm and fpkm
not filtered now these are txt files so
they are tab delimited but if you're on
Mac you can simply drag this in Excel if
you're using Windows you just do a right
and select Excel or if you have any
other table manipulation software than
should also work and you see the table
that we just saw in the presentation
idea of a gene and here's an example
gene and then we can see some numbers
and we will talk about what these
markets are here in a second okay so as
you can see this would be a single
sample so how many samples can you have
okay we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven examples
okay then we have genes okay so let's
look how many genes do you have thanks
for each one is Eugenia D how many you
have to go to the end you will see that
we have about 20,000 genes so these
20,000 genes or let's look at the
numbers okay so what is this number
no let's go back to the top and let's
take a look at the numbers that we have
in here any number that you select so
what is this 10.12
willing me alright so in this example
you see 3.27 so it's right here so what
is this number okay
let's take a look at the different
methods we have to quantify the number
of greens that were aligned to the gene
first of all we have the option of just
simply counting them the second option
is called fpkm that's the one that we
use and that stands for fragments for
kilobase per million mapped reads in
other words we are aligning this to have
an normalization for the length right so
we are just taking a million math reads
as our baseline and then we are using
every count adjusting it to what
distribution of beads we have in general
and then a very similar approach is TPM
so instead of doing fragments we can do
full transcripts transferred
good morning and you can learn more
about this if you go into the our SEM
publication and read about the algorithm
itself now another thing to consider is
whether we are using linear scale or a
log scale a lot of times you will see
that the initial output is going to be
in linear scale but it's very useful to
normalize it by applying log scale to
the numbers but once we do that we also
need to understand that now it changes
the proportions that we are looking in
terms of the differences
you
well reduce the numbers but we will also
have four reduce the differences and we
just need to again be like okay so let's
do a quick review of what we did here
first of all we looked at pre-processing
steps removing adapters and PCR
duplicates we then went over different
mapping options known transcripts
mapping on genome and potential
identification of novel transcripts and
then a combined strategy and then
finally we looked at quantification of
expression levels now the question about
using the pre-processing steps as you
remember we used at least two methods of
trimming and reducing duplicates does
that really have an effect on the
outcome so you can see here two graphics
the first one represents a level of
expression on you see over here log
scale okay no duplicates removal and no
pre-processing so they are perfectly
aligned so there's no differences
between them over here on the right side
we see that we have standard
pre-processing and no pre-processing so
is there a difference between them and
yes we can see a difference right here
so in this corner you can see that if we
were not doing any pre-processing our
understanding of highly expressed genes
values of highly expressed genes is
going to be skewed and so that's why
typically you would want to use
pre-processing steps when you are trying
to analyze the differences between
samples for example okay now if you have
any questions let's go over them now
I'll just remind you that a lot of these
things are described in detail in our
free online courses transcriptomics 1 &
2 deal primarily with the issues that we
have been discussing today let me know
if you have any question
about what we did so far so you can
either speak um or if you want to type
them out that's also fine okay
no questions so far it seems let me then
go on so here are some of the questions
that we had in previous sessions as you
saw on the platform there are a few
other options there's air correction
there are different mappers and so the
question would be okay so why do we have
so many different mappers and then we
also have a differential expression
section and segmentation right so we
have differential expression and
segmentation by the way before we
continue I just want to mention that you
will see this now sign on some of the
buttons the Tao sign represents an
algorithm that was developed at the Tao
Burbank cymatics Research Center and
it's a custom approach to this general
topic other algorithms you can download
them online they're open source and you
can run them typically in a Linux
environment you can run them and if you
know how to give them the right input
and the right modifications to the
inputs then you will get the same output
on what this platform does is it helps
connect the original interface all of
these different methods into a single
pipeline and run it on the servers that
we support and you have 14 days to use
the platform feel free and if you are
interested in using this platform for
research or for education you can just
let us know and we can help you figure
that next step back so error correction
is typically a section used for
microarray data and low quality
sequencing data
we have different mappers but they are
organized by their function so you can
click on a section and read about the
section itself and then the other issue
is with the eggs on tables we reviewed
that differential gene expression will
actually create a differential gene
expression pipe on labor on and then
segmentation is the section that is
useful in specific cases but as you can
see a lot of the algorithms are custom
so we're not going to be talking about
them right now
machine learning so now we're going to
review what to do with this expression
table using machine learning the person
presenting this will be Stefania [ __ ]
on from the table and Mattocks
researcher
hello so let us start from understanding
what is machine learning about and
generally machine learning is separated
into two ways first is unsupervised
machine learning and second is
supervised machine learning first let us
discuss unsupervised machine learning
approaches and what is all about suppose
we have a lot of samples this example
our samples are some bad images and
actually we don't know which pad is on
which image so we don't know that this
is the dog this is a character and the
aim of unsupervised machine learning is
to mark these samples so for example we
can mark them into this way dogs and
research cats so in unsupervised machine
learning we have unmarked samples and we
need to mark that
for example we can draw them on the
plane so you see that dogs are distinct
from the cats
so we have u 1 and u 2 and sometimes we
can have outliers for example head dog
which can't be in each of these moves
and in our case our samples are cell
lines and our features are genes so we
have gene expression table and first
method of unsupervised analysis is just
to draw our samples on the plane what's
the problem in our case we have 7,000
genes 7,000 features so we can draw them
on the plane because our samples are
actually points in seven thousand
dimensional space and it can be can't be
drawn from the computer so our aim is to
have some projection of this data to the
plane but not project not all the
projections from high dimensional data
to the plane are actually good for
example okay let's look at my finger for
example okay or to the yeah yeah so this
is a pre dimensional object and you see
actually two dimensional projection on
your screen so for example I can turn it
this way and you see just some circle
and you can understand that this is
actually cut but if I will turn it in
that way you see the optimal projection
and you can understand that this is
actually how so the aim of principal
component analysis is to perform
projection of high dimensional data to
the plane in order to maximize
information which which is associated
with the data on the plane so we can
open our platform and try to run
principal component analysis on on the
expression table here we have section
data mining and
unsupervised analysis then we need to
upload files here our files are not so
big so we can
you